are you the person in the group who is
always getting bitten by mosquitoes
because i certainly am and science has
shown that this is a thing that
mosquitoes are more attractive to some
people than others and the reason for
that is at least partially genetic which
is why this video is supported by
23andme a company that reads sections of
your genetic code and then helps you
understand what's in there now they've
actually been involved in some research
that has identified particular spots on
your dna that make you more or less
likely to be attractive to mosquitoes
and in this video i want to put that to
the test so i flew to new mexico state
university to meet mosquito man
professor imo hansen
hello
we have a collection of uh lab strains
here he maintains colonies of many
different species of mosquitoes and one
exotic strain he actually feeds with his
own blood no no i'm serious these ones
are made from my blood really yes
absolutely yeah i'm the only one eating
them i can't ask my students you know
that would be a whole a nightmare
getting permissions how do you feed them
well with just sticking your arms just
put my arm in there and wait
is it psychologically itchy or no it is
really itchy
yeah and i'm getting i mean 25 bites or
so right now
mosquitoes need our blood proteins to
make their eggs so only the female
mosquitoes bite
the eggs hatch into these wriggly larvae
which develop into pupae before becoming
flying adult mosquitoes then they once
again seek out vertebrate blood to make
more eggs the whole life cycle takes
just two weeks
but what i wanted to know is am i a
desirable target
how can we figure out if i'm attractive
to mosquitoes okay we have a white tube
basically which has a holding chamber we
put the mosquitoes down here there's a
little fan producing a draft something
like four meters per second we're gonna
insert a bait into one of these chambers
and the green or the yellow one so by
bait you're saying me yes you exactly
you put your hand in there uh would be
good if you would rub your hand first so
uh if you're sweating whales yes
right this is a great stuff
exactly
it is
almost feeds exclusively on humans
they're really specialized on biting
humans
that's good to know yeah
there's 20 mosquitoes in the holding
chamber and they're going to decide
whether to come and find me or go down
the other side and
they find nothing right we're releasing
the mosquitoes yeah i see them coming oh
he's chosen wrong
do you see that
man you are attractive i mean
you are a strong attractant to mosquitos
they all went in your direction none of
them went the other way yes
this is
amazing
oh there's one
i did not i did not expect to have such
a strong response like
you see all those mosquitoes
this type of test was actually used to
discover that the basis for our
attractiveness to mosquitoes is at least
partially genetic researchers recruited
18 pairs of identical female twins and
19 pairs of non-identical or fraternal
female twins then they used the y-tube
test to evaluate the mosquito
attractiveness of each individual
measured by the fraction of mosquitoes
who correctly flew to the arm of the
tube where the twin was standing
what scientists found is that the
mosquito attractiveness of twins is
correlated that is the more attractive
you are to mosquitoes the more likely
your twin is too
but that's not all that surprising and
could be caused by environmental factors
or a common diet but comparing identical
twins to fraternal twins revealed the
correlation was higher for identical
twins
this strongly suggests genetics
influence how attractive you are to
mosquitoes since the identical twins
share more of the same genes than
fraternal twins this explains why their
mosquito attractiveness would be more
closely correlated if it really is
genetics that determines how much
mosquitoes like you with that last test
i was clearly attractive to these
mosquitoes yes except we weren't
comparing me to any other human we were
just comparing me to a control exactly
yes no human
so what if we compare myself with my
wife raquel
normally i get bitten and she doesn't
okay so this should be a good test maybe
to see whether under lab conditions
we can reproduce zero we'll we'll
produce our anecdotal findings exactly
anecdotal evidence
once again
preparing
okay hands in position yeah yeah see
they they actually start to wake up they
smelled some of something something's
going on here
okay what are we saying
whoa
i'm getting a good amount over here but
so are you
let's see i think i'm getting more you
it looks to me like you got three
okay we want to stop the experiment
right now all right
okay now let's count i think it's seven
on your side here
five in the holding
five in the holding
and quite a few on your side
so who gets bitten i get better you get
bitten in reality we would repeat this
experiment maybe eight times or so right
and switching you guys around but uh i
think
this is
a good way to show how this works
okay so that result was not particularly
scientifically rigorous but it did
reproduce our experience in the wild
which is that i am much more attractive
well at least when it comes to
mosquitoes
than raquel
but the question is i guess does this
come down to our genetics yeah so we
spat into some tubes and sent them off
to be tested right and we were
interested in seven particular locations
on our dna which were located in a 2017
study that involved 23 and me so the way
23andme works is when you sign up you
can opt in to be part of research and 16
000 people agreed to be part of this
study and rate their perceived
attractiveness to mosquitoes so then
what the scientists did was a
genome-wide association study that is
they looked at all the dna of all of
those participants and
tried to see if there were commonalities
amongst the people who said they were
attractive mosquitoes and that were
different to the people who said they
weren't attractive to mosquitoes and
they identified seven particular
locations on the dna seven single letter
changes which seemed to be associated
with different levels of attractiveness
to mosquitoes so we have our results
back and do you want to see them i do i
do i'm very curious all right um let's
pull it up here okay so of the seven
locations that are related to mosquito
attractiveness it turns out we have the
identical dna at four of them so you can
rule those out which leaves only three
areas where we actually have differing
dna so at the first location you have
one copy of a letter change which
actually makes you significantly
protected from mosquitoes oh no way yeah
it's associated with decreased
attractive two mosquitoes i do not have
any letter changes at that location uh
now at the second location where we
differ i have a letter change compared
to you that makes me
uh less attractive to mosquitoes so more
protected interesting if you look at the
significance of those two letter changes
yours is about twice as significant okay
than mine but still we both have a
protective letter switch so in the last
snip we actually differ significantly
and i have two copies of a variant that
makes me more attractive to mosquitoes
this was the only snip which was
associated with being more attractive to
mosquitoes and i have two copies of that
change and you have no copies of that
change so that makes sense so overall i
would say our genetics really adds up
here and of course we can't say that
this proves that it is right but it is
definitely consistent with these snips
actually being associated with your
attractiveness to mosquitoes and that
sort of borne out by our experience
that's so cool
now it's unclear exactly how these
genetic changes might make us more or
less attractive to mosquitoes but it's
likely that it has something to do with
the odor or the volatile chemicals that
our bodies give off and due to the
microbiome the bacteria on our skin
one of the main signals that mosquitoes
like to follow is carbon dioxide so that
means if you have a higher metabolism or
if you've just been exercising or if
you're a bigger person or even if you're
pregnant you are more likely to attract
mosquitoes but mosquitoes are also
attracted to some other volatiles that
we give off things like lactic acid
acetone and ammonia but scientists have
also found some chemicals that repel or
appear to impair mosquitoes ability to
find us those chemicals we naturally
give off are octanal nonanal decanal and
6-methyl 5-heptane 2-ohm so why is this
important well the researchers estimate
that our attractiveness to mosquitoes is
about as hereditary as height or iq that
is to say genetics play a significant
role here so understanding that
relationship is really important
especially when you consider that of all
the animals mosquitoes have the greatest
impact on human health are mosquitoes
the worst animal of all time absolutely
absolutely there's no question about
that malaria has killed more people than
people have killed people they are the
most dangerous animal in the world
by some estimates mosquitoes have killed
more than half of the humans who have
ever lived
now that estimate has been debated and
is likely too high but even so this year
over a million people will die of
mosquito-borne illnesses so if not half
certainly a significant number of humans
have died due to mosquitoes probably
more than any other single cause
which led me to wonder do you think
humans may have evolved this trait to
smell worse to mosquitoes as an
adaptation to avoid the diseases or is
it just by accident that some people are
less attractive to mosquitoes than
others
that is a really good question
and while we're on the subject of
evolution consider this
if you ever contract malaria it actually
changes your body chemistry to make you
produce an odor that makes you more
attractive to mosquitoes
think about that the malaria parasite
has evolved so that when it's in its
host
it makes the host more attractive to
mosquitoes
mosquitoes are the thing that transmit
malaria
it's phenomenal i mean evolution is
incredible
this episode of veritasium is supported
by 23 and me a company whose name comes
from the fact that humans have 23 pairs
of chromosomes and the point of the
company is to help people understand
what's written in your chromosomes now
at the minute you can't get access to
the mosquito attractiveness test but
maybe one day in the future you will be
able to
right now you can access tons of
information about your physical traits
about aspects of your health and about
where your dna and i guess you come from
so i thought i would share my results
with you i come from all over the world
as you can see from the map but
significantly more from europe about 95
european you can drill down into that
and see that i'm largely british and
irish and french and german with a bit
of scandinavian what's interesting to me
is there's a 3.3
south asian which is something
i think my family suspected but didn't
know for sure so it's interesting the
types of information you can find out
which is stored in your dna so if you
want to find out about the information
in your dna you can go to 23andme.com
veritasium so i want to thank 23andme
for supporting veritasium and i want to
thank you for watching